- Have to be like, I'm
cool and you're not.
It's like, yo.
You know what's fucking cool?
Self awareness.
(mellow instrumental music)
The number one gift my mom gave
me is a lack of entitlement.
What's really empowering
and what's holding so many
people back here is entitlement.
You feel like somebody owes you something
because something went wrong
somewhere along the way.
I don't.
I actually think whatever
went wrong for you
is the best shit that ever happened to you
because adversity is absolutely
the foundation of success.
(audience applause and cheers)
Nobody owes you shit.
- [Driver] First one is from Nicholas
and his question is how
do you create content
if your life is boring?
And I did some research
and I'm getting a vibe
that he's like a Shopify seller of sorts.
It says a lot of his work is
just having a computer at home.
- You know, I think a lot
of things are boring, man.
I think I'm boring.
I think a lot of it--
- That's why I liked it
is 'cause most of your life
is just sitting at a desk--
- Yeah, man.
- and meetings.
- Yeah, honestly,
I want to make sure you're a
part of this post right now.
I'm a fuckin' business man.
I don't know, like, playing
soccer is boring to some people.
Painting is boring to some people.
You don't get to judge
for the other person.
If somebody's trying to
learn how to flip and sell
and if you can just get to a
place where as you're working,
you're talking,
like right now I'm posting this.
And I used this title
because if you use three
exclamation points,
I've noticed that I've sold more.
And ah, shit,
I've gotta go to the post
office now and pack it.
It's the grind and it's the dirt
that nobody wants to talk about.
It's not glamorous,
it's not champaign bottles
and fuckin' models,
but I gotta go to the fuckin' post office
if I want to build a
foundation of my business.
To me everything is potentially remarkable
and potentially boring.
You just need to document
it and not create.
And then you gotta let the world decide
if you're boring or you're not.
And then you also have to
ebb and flow and be patient.
I don't know if, news alert,
I don't know if anybody's
paying attention,
but my views on my fuckin' daily vlog
are down year over year.
Ask me if I give a fuck.
Ask me.
Short-term vanity metrics mean shit
and all of you are poisoned
by the sizzle behind them.
I've never been happier
and my views are down
on YouTube. (laughing)
Ya know?
- Yeah.
- Documenting.
- [Driver] Next question.
I thought this would be a
good one based on today,
is how do you land and
grab and take advantage
sort of early mover
opportunities for IGTV?
- You know, to me it's
about producing content
that's native to a platform, right?
The number one thing you
want to do is create content
that is native to a platform.
And I think right now what
I'm trying to figure out
is what's native to IGTV.
Obviously, we're doing
this entire DailyVee
in IGTV format in vertical, right?
You know, you've been watching
Batman hold the camera
and now is awkward and
exciting all at once.
And so to me will that matter?
Hmm, it's a thesis.
But to me the people that
tend to win platforms
are the ones that innovate
or understand the context
of a platform.
You either saw a platform
in a different way
then everybody else did,
and you changed the game.
And I'll be very honest with you,
one of the things that I don't
think I peacock enough about
is long form video on YouTube in 2006.
Nobody was doin' it.
I never,
I do a very bad job proppin' me up
on something that I innovated.
I was like, why can't it be long?
I think being in the why business,
like, just asking questions matters.
Why can't IGTV, you know, like,
Who's doing content as a vlogger
who decides to just make
their IGTV an animation?
Or is it just vertical?
Will that be enough?
Or commercials.
I don't know, like, why can't
we just have commercials
in the middle of,
What if I stop right now
and it's just a commercial
for the K-Swiss 003.
(camera shuttering)
You gotta innovate and
you gotta understand it.
You gotta be empathetic to
somebody sitting on their phone
watching it like this, right?
What does that mean?
Like, do you do funny,
Do you remember with SpongeBob,
when he was like (weird mouth noises).
All that weird shit.
Maybe every seven minutes
we just do something like
put your coffee down or,
Pay attention, yo, pay attention.
You know, like, I don't know.
Innovation and context.
Innovating on a platform
or respecting the context
of a platform are the two
people that always break out.
And then you layer the talent
or the interesting thing
that the person does.
(mellow instrumental music)
- [Drama] How are you, man?
- [Gary] Really good, good to see ya.
- Good to see you, man.
- Real pleasure.
- You good?
- [Gary] Everything's super good.
What's up, man? How are you?
- What's up. Tyler.
- Tyler. Gary.
- [Tyler] Nice to meet you.
- So I'd already built a business.
My family's liquor store business.
I'd already,
I lived the life.
I was thirty four.
I lived a life before all
this shit started happening.
And just watching entrepreneurship
be put on a pedestal
is exciting and also scary.
I will tell you that one
of the number one fears
I have is too many kids
want to be an entrepreneur
even though they're not.
- Yeah, that's what's
interesting is because
I think that entrepreneurship
is having a moment
and also you're directly
out in front of it.
You know what I mean?
It's having a moment and you are the guy.
Do you know how many people,
and how many meetings I go into now,
and everyone now has a camera guy?
- [Gary] Oh, yeah.
- And that's literally 100%, I think,
influenced by what you're doing.
But my question is,
So obviously that's cool
and that's a discussion
that a lot of people have on this podcast
is like, yeah, everyone's
an entrepreneur now.
And I'd say I think that the good news is
there will be more real
entrepreneurs out of this, right?
- Oh, totally.
To your point, net.
There are thousands, tens of thousands.
And I would argue hundreds of thousands
and maybe even millions
who during this era
find entrepreneurship.
The freedoms that come with it.
The beauty of it that
wouldn't have 20 years ago
'cause they would've been executives.
What I'm worried about
is the collateral damage.
- [Drama] What do you
think happens to the person
that's caught in the crossfire?
- I think there's some
people who commit suicide.
I think there's some people that,
You have to understand why I say that.
Depression, 'cause you can't hide.
When your T-shirt business
fails 'cause the economy fails
and influencers don't get
paid like that anymore,
and shit hits the fan and
you go work at Citibank,
your family and friends know.
One of the things I did really well
was I lived humble as fuck.
I lived in a fuckin' one bedroom apartment
in Springfield, New Jersey.
It didn't cost much.
I didn't get fancy and move to New York.
I never went out.
So really easy to save
money when you don't spend
a thousand bucks on a
weekend hitting it hard.
And I saved, I saved, I saved.
I didn't have a lot of money,
but everything I had I bet
on Facebook and Twitter.
This is why I believe people can win.
I wasn't making a lot of money,
I was building a business
for somebody else.
I just lived humbly.
Everybody wants a,
Some kid just tweeted,
I put out that tweet.
Somebody else is like, yeah.
Other kids are like,
easy for you guys to say.
It was so much easier
in the 70, 80s, and 90s.
I'm like, you're a fucking loser, dick.
We didn't have internet.
What the fuck do you know
about the 70, 80s, and 90s?
You fuckin' suck, bitch.
It's not easier, you're
just lazy and entitled
'cause mommy and daddy
did everything for you
and you think life's
about playing fuckin' Xbox
and smoking weed and fuckin'
drinking Mountain Dew,
you fuckin' asshole.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Go work.
- Yeah.
- (laughing) I just got so pissed.
- [Drama] Good, solid ending.
- Love it. You got it.
- Guy.
- Dude!
- How are you?
- Respect for you.
- Thank you, my man.
What's your name?
- [Man] Oh!
- Yeah, it's always filming.
- [Man] All right, good good.
- What's your name?
- Monte.
- Monte, I'm Gary.
- Nice to meet you.
- I watch all of your videos, man.
- Thank you, my friend.
- That's my favorite.
- I appreciate your work.
- Thank you so much.
- Appreciate that.
- Love the energy.
- Thank you, brother.
- All right.
- [Gary] That was amazing. (laughing)
How are you?
(greetings)
- Getting off at two, huh?
- [Gary] I know, it's exciting.
I'm proud of it.
Are you going, thank you.
(chatter)
How are you, man?
- This is Ned.
- Hey.
- Gary.
- It's such a pleasure, how are you?
- [Man In White Hat] Nice. Bill.
- [Bill] Adsense.
- I mean, look, everybody look.
It's always a branding game.
Always. Life.
All of it.
Religion.
Like college.
Like marriage.
It's all fuckin' branding.
So you know, I think that,
I grew up in a heavily regulated business
that was obviously more mature in the fact
that the rules were
established, but not really.
- [Bill] Or it gives
you rules in 50 states.
- So tough.
- Right? It's so crazy.
- Right.
And was changing and when I
was doing internet marketing,
internet selling was like so gray.
So I know the stomach and
the appetite for this stuff,
but the stakes are so
high when you're right.
And like, it's inevitable.
(mellow instrumental music)
Is that a former Samsung sign?
- [Man] Yes.
(everyone laughing)
- [Gary] That's like one of
the reasons to have a sign.
Even when it comes down,
it's actually still there.
The sun took care of it.